in the previous video you saw how you
can get a neural network to output for
numbers P X py BH + BW to specify the
bounding box of an object you want in
your network to localize in more general
cases you can have a neural network just
output X and y coordinates of important
points in image sometimes called
landmarks they want the neural network
to recognize let me show you a few
examples let's say you're building a
face recognition application and for
some reason you want the algorithm to
tell you where is the corner of
someone's eye so that point has an x and
y coordinate so you can just have a
neural network have is you know final
layer and have it just output two more
numbers which I'm gonna call our X and
our Y to just tell you the coordinates
of that corner of the person's eye now
what if you wanted to tell you you know
all four corners of the eye are really
of both eyes so if we call the points
the first second third and four points
going from left to right then you can
modify the neural network now to output
l1 X 1 Y for the first point and l2 X
two Y for the second point and so on so
that the neural network can output the
estimated position of all those four
points of the person's face but what if
you don't want just those four points
what do you want to output at this point
at this point at this point at this
point you know along the eye maybe
output some key points along the mouth
so you can extract the mouth shape and
tell the person is smiling or frowning
maybe extract a few key points along the
edges of the nose but you could define
some number for the sake of argument
let's say 64 points or 64 landmarks on
the face maybe even some points you know
that helps you define the edge of the
face it defines the jawline but by
selecting a number of landmarks and
generating a label training set that
contains all of these landmarks you can
then have the
network will tell you where are all the
key positions or the key landmarks on a
face so what you do is you have this
image person's face as input have it go
through a confident and have a confident
then have some set of features maybe
have it output zero or one like is there
a face in this or not and then have it
also output o1x l1y and so on down to no
64x64 why and here I'm using L to stand
for a landmark so this example would
have 129 output units 1 4 is where a
face or not and then if you have 64
landmark stats 64 times 2 so 128 plus 1
output units and this can tell you if
there's a face as well as where all the
key landmarks on the face so you know
this is a basic building block for
recognizing emotions from faces and if
you played with the snapchat and the
other entertainment you know self AR
augmented reality filter so if the
snapchat filters can only draw a crown
on the face and have other special
effects being able to detect these
landmarks on the face is also a key
building block for the computer graphics
effects that warp the face or draw on
various special effects like for the
crown of our hats on a person of course
in order to trade a network like this
you will need a label training set we
have a set of images as well as labels Y
where people where someone would have
had to go through and laborious ly
annotate all of these landmarks one last
example if you are interested in people
post-detection you could also define a
few key positions like the midpoint of
the chest that should the left shoulder
left elbow the wrist and so on and just
have a neural network you know
annotate key positions in the person's
pose as well and by having a neural
network output all of those points down
annotating you could also have the
neural network output the pose of the
person and of course to do that you also
need to specify on these key landmarks
which may be l1 X and l1 Y is the
midpoint of the chest down to maybe oh
32 X Oh
32 Y if you study two coordinates to
specify the pose of the person so this
idea it might seem quite simple of just
adding a bunch of output units to output
the XY coordinates of different
landmarks you want to recognize to be
clear the identity of landmark one must
be consistent across different images
like maybe landmark one is always this
corner of the eye
Lima 2 is always this corner of the eye
lamech 3 landmark 4 and so on so the
labels have to be consistent across
different images but if you can hire
laborers or laborer yourself a big
enough data set to do this then a neural
network can output you know all of these
landmarks you shouldn't use to carry out
other interesting effects I just
estimate the posing person maybe try to
recognize someone's emotion from a
picture and so on so that's it for
landmark detection next let's take these
building blocks and use it to start
building up towards object detection